[Music]
hello everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to Fandango indie movie Guide and as
well as seeing Isle of Dogs this weekend
I can't wait here are three great indie
gems out in theaters this weekend let's
start with unsane by Steven Soderbergh
this does Claire Foy as a woman who's
committed to a mental institution which
may or may not be voluntary and it's
also not clear if she's having paranoid
delusions about someone stalking her or
if it's actually happening she's still
soon your stalker everywhere rationally
I know this is my imagination but I'm
alone in a strange city and I never feel
safe this is all shot on an iPhone and
apparently Steven Soderbergh wanted to
put it out under a pseudonym maybe one
of the ones he's used before like his
parents names Peter Andrews Oh Mary Ann
Bernard but it does feel like a
Soderbergh film and the way he uses the
camera the spiky wit about modern
technology albeit in a horror format
it's also very timely delving into every
woman's fear of having to fend off
advances which might turn ugly if the
guy refuses and all of our fears of not
being able to trust our own minds he's
followed me all the way here from boss
the film really works best when it makes
you question what you are seeing and
although it gets a little bit unwieldy
towards the end it does show that Steven
Soderbergh is still curious about making
movies and that is a great thing
considering he retired for a little bit
you can see unseen in theaters from this
weekend he's here or maybe it's all in
my head the change is another little
indie film I recommend you watching it's
directed by Rachel Israel it's about two
people on the autism spectrum who start
dating after they meet at an acting
class you do raises people are wearing
that don't you you wanna be like they
won't be normal like me no it's a
learning and the reason why this film
stands apart from the rest is that the
two actors are on the autism spectrum so
you don't have neuro normative actors
playing autistic and it really does add
a whole new sense of authenticity to the
film plus the two actors Brandon
Polanski and Samantha Alyssa fun are so
charming to watch and the movie also
doesn't shy away from some tough
subjects you can see keep the change in
LA from this weekend and then a national
rollout after that what did the dog say
to the bartender what put it on my bill
and last but not least is final portrait
directed by Stanley Tucci this is set in
1964 and tells the true story of Italian
artist Alberto Giacometti who painted a
portrait of American writer James Lord
played by Army hammer which was only
supposed to be quick but ended up taking
a long time this is what's going on I
just want to show happening was a paper
to me but I'm unable to do that now the
movie doesn't go deep into the lives of
the subjects so this is more of just a
nice way to spend an afternoon it's set
in beautiful Paris there are lush
close-ups of art being created and the
cast is strong there's no real big
themes or messages think about
afterwards but I enjoyed being in this
chaotic art world and you can too from
this weekend in limited theaters it's
gone too far
same time not far enough we could always
just stop oh we can't stop
so there you have it if you're venturing
out this weekend see I love dogs of
course and then also see unseen by
steven soderbergh keep the change the
cute romantic comedy and final portrait
for a lovely look at the art world as
always let me know in the comments below
what you are seeing this weekend and I'd
also like to know what is your favorite
Steven Soderbergh movie let me know I'll
see you next week bye